en el vídeo anterior usamos números
completos para calcular la rapidez y
desplazamiento de un proyectil lanzado
hacia arriba durante cierto tiempo ahora
vamos a ver una generalización de esto
para encontrar algunas fórmulas
interesantes para hacer los cálculos
mentalmente y rápidamente digamos que la
pelota se encuentra en el aire durante
un periodo de tiempo o un cambio de
tiempo delta de esto es el tiempo
de la pelota en el aire tiempo en el
aire desde que se soltó la soltamos de
nuestra mano hasta que cae al suelo y el
tiempo hacia arriba
a diferencia del tiempo arriba es el
tiempo
que le tardo a la pelota o quitado la
pelota desde que la soltamos hasta
detenerse hasta llegar a su altura
máxima y este tiempo hacia arriba va a
ser igual a el tiempo en el aire
dividido entre 2 la mitad de este
periodo como les digo asumiendo que no
tenemos ninguna resistencia al aire
entonces bueno tenemos estos definidos
estos elementos cuál va a ser nuestra
velocidad inicial sólo tenemos que
recordar que el cambio en la velocidad
es lo mismo que la velocidad final menos
la velocidad inicial entonces recordamos
que el cambio en la velocidad
es igual a bueno tengo que poner estos
son vectores que no se me olvide poner
la natación es igual a
la velocidad
final vamos a ponerla en dos colores
velocidad final menos
la velocidad inicial y aquí sabemos que
nuestra velocidad final va a ser cero
entonces este término lo podemos quitar
y podemos establecer que el cambio de
velocidad
es igual a un vector que no se me olvide
la anotación para no confundirlos
el cambia la velocidad
igual
menos la velocidad inicial
entonces también tenemos que si sabemos
de la fórmula de la aceleración y
tenemos que la aceleración va a ser
constante porque estamos trabajando con
la gravedad terrestre que está no cambia
esta velocidad inicial base de igual
a menos bueno la aceleración que le
estamos poniendo como
- 9.8
punto 8 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
y esto x
el cambio del periodo entre dos
simplificamos esto esto es igual a 9.8
entre 2
esto es igual
4.9 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado por
la diferencia en el tiempo el cambio en
el periodo del tacto
y este del tate es el tiempo total el
tiempo que tardó en subir y bajar no es
la mitad del periodo no es el tiempo
hacia arriba si quisiéramos dejar esta
velocidad inicial en términos del tiempo
hacia arriba entonces en la velocidad
inicial sería igual
el 9.8
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
pero ahora x delta te hacia arriba que
es la mitad de el periodo total entonces
bueno así es como podríamos tener la
fórmula en este otro término ahora vamos
a ver el desplazamiento
el desplazamiento
es igual a nuestra velocidad promedio
velocidad promedio
pons
el cambio de tiempo total a la mitad
entre 2 y recordamos que esto bueno esto
también lo podemos poner como si fuera
el tiempo hacia arriba es lo mismo del
tate arriba
aquí vemos el dt arriba es la mitad del
tate del tiempo completo y también
sabemos que nuestra velocidad promedio
nuevamente 'www hincapié en que si
estamos en un trabajando con aceleración
constante es cuando podemos hacer esta
asumir esto o usar esta fórmula la
velocidad promedio va a ser igual a la
velocidad final más la velocidad inicial
entre 2
de nuevo mi velocidad final es 0
entonces mi velocidad promedio va a ser
igual
menos
mi velocidad inicial
entre 2
me acabo de dar cuenta que tengo un
error tremendo aquí es la suma de las
dos velocidades velocidad final más
velocidad inicial entonces esto no es
menos esto más hacer la velocidad
inicial entre 2 bueno entonces tengo que
aquí ya le había calculado mi velocidad
inicial en terminen estos términos
este es un s l cuadrado
entonces voy a sustituir esta fórmula
como en esta parte de la velocidad
promedio perdón de los 100 en la fórmula
de la velocidad de promedio entonces
queremos que es igual a mi velocidad
inicial que aquí mi velocidad inicial
fue de 4.9 metros sobre segundo al
cuadrado x
el periodo de tiempo que estuvo en el
aire total mi pelota y todo esto lo voy
a dividir
entre 2 y así queda mi fórmula de la
velocidad de promedio ahora esta fórmula
que acabamos de derivar
la vamos a sustituir aquí en la
velocidad promedio en la fórmula del
desplazamiento mi desplazamiento va a
quedar
igual a la velocidad promedio que fue en
4.9 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
la del tate fueron 5 pero todavía no las
voy a sustituir por el cambio en el
tiempo
estate
post
bueno esto entre 2
en mi velocidad promedio x del pp entre
2 que es esta parte entonces vamos a
simplificar esta fórmula y esto nos
queda
4.2 por 24 entonces aquí abajo nos va a
quedar un 4
nos queda aquí arriba 4.9
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado y del
tate por delta t nos queda delta de al
cuadrado simplificamos este 4 con este
nos queda 1 y el desplazamiento nos va a
resultar en
1 punto bueno vivimos 4.94 no es que sea
nula 4.9 entre 4 vamos a calcular cuánto
es
4.9 entre 4 1.225 225 por el periodo de
tiempo
al cuadrado
y esta es el desplazamiento máximo que
tanto hasta qué distancia llegó la
pelota
el desplazamiento máximo de la pelota
hacia arriba 1.225 punto multiplicado
por el tiempo que tome que estuvo esta
pelota en el aire que yo me dedico mi
cronómetro al cuadrado y esa es la
fórmula muy sencilla para calcular este
valor vamos a usar estas fórmulas para
corroborar los valores de los cálculos
que hicimos en el vídeo anterior en el
vídeo anterior nuestro desplazamiento
como perdón nuestro tiempo en el aire de
la pelota era de 5 segundos entonces
a la velocidad inicial
venía haciendo
4.9 por el periodo total entonces mi
velocidad inicial en este caso
y 4.9 por 5
4.9 por 524 punto cinco metros sobre
segundo y el desplazamiento máximo de la
pelota es igual a
a 1.225
punto 225 por 5 al cuadrado 5 por 5 25
por 25 y es igual a 30 puntos 625 metros
que son exactamente los mismos
resultados que obtuvimos en el vídeo
anterior y así hemos encontrado una
expresión sencilla en la que asumiendo
que la resistencia del aire es nula se
puede calcular el desplazamiento máximo
hacia arriba en función a el tiempo en
la que la pelota estuvo en el aire